inferno in the remnants of atlantic city
continues to rage on
the 10 000 acre dumping ground ranks
among the world's
largest and contains both toxic and
biological waste
already seven firefighters combating the
blaze have died and another 40 have
suffered from severe burns and toxin
exposure
the swedish academy award for literature
has been amongst its latest recipient
virginia manchester her most recent book
in the shade of an apple tree as a
treasure of this generation
granchester who is an ai created by
foreign
so what's up
there's just something about a surprise
yesterday am i remembering right or
just had a brain fog probably both
because
you usually forget [ __ ] but it just so
happens
i think i might have bagged this as
sweet ass j.o.b
go on i mean maybe it's not as big as
that but
just that he's fronted by a little known
someone named dexter deshawn
only the top fixer in knight [ __ ]
city
badass black jesus of the afterlife
300 pounds of partly gold-plated
coop our decks bounced out of the ring a
few years ago
mastered the nasty crew in pacifica
things got ugly
gang wars two years back somehow dex got
caught up in the craziness
a lot of bodies lying in the streets by
the time the shooting stopped
yeah dicks got lucky though managed to
slip under the radar till tempers cooled
took a while but he's made one hell of a
comeback
eyes up to his elbows of blood jack you
want to shake his hand
work with him it's the biz b
everyone's got blood on their hands you
deal with it
you move on
so what's the gig we meant to come out
in one piece
our lord and savior wants to tell you
everything himself face to face
no pressure but uh
why do i gotta go you and t-bug draw
straws without me
debugging dex go way back and my face is
yesterday's news
deck says he needs to check you talk to
you
look v it's his job his rules i can't
blame him for taking a personal approach
and it ain't as bad as you think okay
trust me
i guess i got no choice then
dex is a real deal when it comes to
fixers don't get me wrong
don't got nothing against the padre or
wacaco but
don't get me started on fixers they
catch a client
find the cheapest gong to do the job
then drop the corpse at a landfill
[ __ ] hit the nail on the head
brought your wheels given to my guy
yesterday to school over the dance after
our uh
dust stopping scabs thanks jake
much appreciated
some top-notch work miguel did rides
like it looks
factory we'll see about that
are we rolling or what let's feel this
factory new ride
first stop ripper duck and holmes
easy on the gas huh i just ate
i was supposed to stop by vixx anyhow i
got a date
me and miss d you don't say she's
so sweet really gets me you know
[Music]
electronics
hey v dr vector will see you now
balloons
vicky surprise every old ripper it's
good to see it
good to see you too
what do i owe the pleasure today last
gig
had to jack into a client's neurosocket
i think i might have gotten spiked
experiencing migraines nausea
hypersensitivity to bright lights
whole kitten caboodle all right kit
we'll sort you out in a flash besides
that
how are things
need some new kit but tools not toys vic
time i bumped up my sights and got a
grip
really now finally
vic shit's getting real got a job from
dex to sean
hitting the major leagues any tech that
can perform
the dexter desean well
that is something but let me guess
hasn't paid you yet
quit crying vic i'll bring you the
eddies later with
interest you know i will hmm
last time you're here
chair please sit down relax
karoshi optics best i've got and should
be about right under the circumstances
now jack in
karoshi whoa vic nothing tops out on the
market
hmm sounds like it could come in handy
then
you gave me my word i'd pay you back but
this
might be too rich for my blood we'll
work something out
right now i'm just out to make sure you
get back in one piece
eddie's in hand
you peruse and choose while i scan and
see what's going
on inside
uh
uh
uh
mark one like i said decent enough
scanner displays data on your cornea
cherry on the tops of built-in external
lens disruptor
in layman's terms any surveillance cam
will capture your face as a blur
and just remember your body will still
show up as crystal clear
um this should do the trick
talks to karoshi tech too
i'm ready carve away excellent
let's do this
lay that major league arm of yours right
here
just like that thanks
now a bit of anesthetic and i can start
cutting
feel anything
play by play though really doc
makes you sound like a dentist always
going on and on
don't be mean now remember i'm old i got
a shaky ganic hand
good slip lights out for a minute all
right
okay let's test this see the magic in
action
linking you in
you might feel a little discomfort at
first blurred vision
low contrast glitches
well how's it look feel all right to you
oh this is fantastic vic
oh beautiful
for the scanner
it might take you a few seconds to
adjust but
first time's rarely the charm with
anything really
scanner should eventually sync with your
thought processes
and read your intentions
[Applause]
i also inject an ncpd file search
run into any narrative wells you know
exactly what thing there did well
it ought to work like a charm now draw
your weapon
you should see your ammo count on a
brand new site
how about the neuro virus from the last
job can you check it
done and gone while we were putting in
your implant and a full sweep on your
soft and circuits
zap the critter your certified bug free
[ __ ] victor not bad i don't know what to
say
say you'll take this and remember the
dosage two whiffs now
and another two in an hour
what am i looking at a mild stem should
boost neurotransmission in the short
term and muffle some of the side effects
while the implant takes
again vic you're the best i owe you
go on kid show them what you're made of
and once you